en una sesión maratónica que se extendió
hasta las primeras horas del miércoles
el gobierno de Benjamín netanyahu sorteó
las objeciones de la oposición y aprobó
el presupuesto para 2023 y 2024 se trata
de un plano muy cuestionado por un lado
por los sectores seculares de la
sociedad israelí que se volcaron en
protestas para denunciar lo que
califican de saqueo a las arcas públicas
y por el otro por la oposición liderada
por shain quien calificó el plan de
destructivo en el centro de las críticas
están las partidas adicionales
destinadas a subsidios para estudiantes
e instituciones de la comunidad judía
Ultra ortodoxa un sector en el que la
mayoría de los hombres se dedican a los
estudios religiosos se reciben
subvenciones por hecho y evitan trabajar
además de estar exentos de servir en el
ejército por su parte escuelas privadas
Ultra ortodoxas que no brindan materias
básicas como ciencias matemáticas o
inglés también se ven beneficiadas por
fondos adicionales otros sectores de la
oposición cuestionan los cientos de
millones de cheques a los asentamientos
judíos en sí Jordania ocupada que son
considerados ilegales bajo el derecho
internacional todo esto mientras sus
críticos aseguran que el presupuesto no
aborda el alto costo de vida que es la
principal preocupación de los israelíes
letanía juicio oídos sordos a las
críticas y celebró la aprobación del
presupuesto que debía estar listo antes
del 29 de mayo para evitar la caída de
su gobierno de ahí las partidas
adicionales para Ultra ortodoxos y para
el Ministerio del neguev y Galilea que
es controlado por la extrema derecha que
fueron medidas claves para evitar la
rebelión interna y asegurarse los votos
envalentonado el Primer Ministro
vaticinó que su gobierno durará los 4
años previstos y aseguró que la
controvertida reforma judicial volverá a
estar en el centro de la agenda Aunque
aclaró que espera lograr avances en las
negociaciones con la oposición para
conseguir que esta reforma se dé por
consenso